We can get Live Input, Audio and Video, directly
under our App by using an API called getUserMedia. This
is a simple example where we just call getUserMedia,
passing some constraints that say we want video, and then
we assign the resulting stream to a video element
in the page. Of course, this just gives us a
rectangle with live Video Input. We probably want to
do something with it. If we want to grab Snapshots
like if we want to implement a Camera Application, we can
do this with a canvas context and DrawImage. Whenever we want
to take a Snapshot, we simply grab the image from
the video and we draw it to the camera with DrawImage.
Of course a canvas in different than an image. You
can't directly copy a canvas and paste it somewhere else, or
download it your hard drive or post it to your
social networks. Or any of the other typical User flows centred
around images, but it turns out, canvas has a
handy function to encode itself as an image. The canvas
toDataURL method. Here, instead of displaying the canvas itself,
we're copying the canvas contents as a data earl to
the source of an image tag. And if you
want to save these images to the Mobile's local storage,
you can do that, too, by forcing a download of
a link using the download attribute on an anchor element.
This isn't really downloading the data per se, it's encoded in
the link itself, so you're not really transferring things over the network.